one of the great generalizations we can
make
about the modern world is that it is to
an extraordinary degree
an ugly world if we were to show an
ancestor from 250 years ago
around our cities and suburbs they would
be amazed
at our technology and wealth but shocked
by what we had built why are things
often
so ugly there are at least five
reasons
since the dawn of construction it was
understood that the task of an architect
was not only to make a building
serviceable but also to render it
beautiful
even if the building was a practical one
like an aqueduct or a factory
architects would strive to give it a
maximally pleasing appearance
the romans understood that a water
pumping system might be as beautiful as
a temple
the early victorians felt that even a
factory could have some of the aesthetic
properties of an
elegant country house the milanese
knew that a shopping arcade could carry
some of the ambitions of a cathedral
but when architecture reached modern
times the very word
beauty became taboo the architects of
the modern movement began to wage a war
on what they now described as the
effeminacy
waste and pretension of all the previous
beautifying moves
in an essay called ornament and crime in
1910
the austrian modernist adolph luz argued
that to decorate a building
with anything pretty was a sin
as modernism declared form must follow
function in other words the appearance
of a building
should never be shaped by consideration
for beauty
all that should matter is a basic
material purpose
at the outset this sounded bracing yet
liberating
the 19th century had produced some
pretty over-decorated buildings
in which the beautifying impulse had
reached a decadent stage
at the same time many early modernist
buildings
especially those for wealthy clients
were extremely elegant
in a way that felt novel and cleansing
unfortunately
the dream quickly turned sour when
property developers heard that the
artistic avant-garde
was now promoting a concept of
functionalism they rejoiced
from the most high-brow quarters the
most mean-minded motives
had been given a seal of approval
no longer would these developers have to
spend any money on anything to do with
beauty
in no time sheds and brutal boxes
abounded
modernity became ugly because we forgot
how to articulate
that beauty is in the end as much of a
necessity
for a building as a functioning roof
the ugliness of the modern world rests
on a second intellectual
error the idea that no one knows what's
attractive
in architecture in the pre-modern world
it was widely assumed that there were
precise rules
about what made buildings pleasing in
the west
those rules were codified in a doctrine
known as classicism
created by the greeks and developed by
the romans classicism defined what
elegant buildings
should be like for more than a thousand
five hundred years
recognizably classical forms were used
all over the west from edinburgh to
charleston
bordeaux to san francisco then gradually
a degree of polite disagreement broke
out
some people began to make a case for
other styles for example for the gothic
way of building or perhaps the chinese
alpine or thai styles in time these
debates were resolved
in an extremely respectful way that
happened unfortunately
to provoke some very bad practical
consequences
it was decreed that in matters of visual
taste
no one could really win an argument all
tastes deserved a hearing there was no
such thing
as an objective standard of beauty
attractiveness in architecture was just
a multifaceted
subjective phenomenon once again
this was music to property developers
ears
suddenly no one would be allowed to
describe a building as
ugly after all taste was merely
subjective
you and your friends might dislike a new
district even a democratic majority
might loathe it
but that was only in the end a personal
judgment
not some kind of important edict one
might need to listen to
cities grew ever uglier but no one was
ever allowed to say that there was such
a thing as ugliness
after all isn't taste just a very very
personal thing
for most of history it was well
understood that the last thing one
needed in an architect was
originality no more than one would want
originality
in a carpenter or a bricklayer the job
of an architect was just to turn out a
building
roughly like all the others architecture
was
beautifully impersonal and repetitive
but in the early 20th century a
troubling idea came to the fore
that the architect was a distinctive
individual with a unique vision
which needed to be expressed this might
have been liberation for architects
but society as a whole paid an enormous
price for this creative release
suddenly architects began to compete to
create the most outlandish
and shocking forms we lost our ability
to say
that what we really craved was buildings
that looked a bit like they'd always
done
buildings that one wouldn't ever have to
wonder who did
them
for most of history humans lived in
tightly organized
neatly aligned streets and squares not
because anyone thought this was
especially attractive
though it is but because it was
convenient
when you had to get around on foot or at
best on horseback
it paid to keep things close together
furthermore
it was safer because invaders might
attack at any time
and it was crucial to ring your town
with a wall adding further impetus to
keep everything well arranged inside
like a compact cutlery drawer or tool
kit
but without anyone quite noticing with
the spread of cars in the 1920s
the pressure to use space neatly
evaporated
one could now lounge on the earth or
sprawl
lazily across it highways could meander
between
towers bits of scrub land and
scatterings of warehouses
the nervous and precise among us who
like things to be neatly lined up
who were disturbed when a picture is
slightly askew or the knife and fork
aren't equidistant from the plate
grew ever more sorrowful
architects had once had no option but to
build in materials
that were both natural and local this
had two advantages
firstly as a general rule one can't go
very wrong with natural materials you
have to try very hard to make an
ugly stone or wood building it's
difficult to build very high in them for
a start
so your eyesore is guaranteed a certain
modesty
and the inherent organic beauty of
timber and limestone
granite or marble attenuates any errors
at the level of form secondly it can
help to orient us
and connect us to particular places if
they don't look like they could be
anywhere on earth if jerusalem is built
in one sort of stone
and bath in another but modernity
introduced glass and steel
out of which large and imposing
structures could quickly be formed
and it suggested that it would be as
daft to have a local kind of
architecture
as it would be to have a local kind of
mobile phone
or bicycle the argument once again
forgot about human nature
when we say that a building looks like
it could be from anywhere
we're not praising its global ambitions
we're expressing a longing for buildings
to remind us
of where on the earth we really are
we pay dearly for bad architecture a
dumb book or song
can be shelved and disturb no one a dumb
building
will stand to facing the earth and
upsetting all who must look at it
for 300 years at least architecture
is on this basis alone the most
important of the arts
and yet it's also the one we're never
taught anything about
all the way through school the promise
of the modern age
has been to make the most important
things available cheaply to all
no longer should lovely food or clothes
holidays or medicines
be just the preserve of the very rich
industrial technology
should open up quality for everyone but
paradoxically
one key ingredient we all long for has
been rendered
far more exclusive than ever through our
inability
to think clearly about architecture the
one thing we haven't been able to mass
produce
are beautiful buildings as a result
the nice architecture there is most of
which was built before 1900
is hugely oversubscribed and collapsing
under a weight of tourists
and the few pleasant streets that remain
are costlier than they ever were at the
height
of the aristocratic era we have
democratized comfort
but we have made beauty appallingly
exclusive
the challenge now is to remember our
longing for beauty
and to fight the forces that would keep
us
from acting on it our book
what is culture for helps us find
compassion
hope and perspective in the arts
you